Faraz starts off this hour in los
angeles hey Feroz how are you good how
are your self it better than I deserve
what's up just have some some issues
with my finances like nature calling the
show of course so I have a BMW car
payment that you know when I bought I
thought I was working in Congress I
guess it's a $600 car payment a month
and make about $1,200 a month and are
you canceling no really I mean where are
you making 1,200 a month when you took
that car payment when I first jumped
into my first car no no the $600 car
payment on the Beemer were you making
1,200 a month when that payment was
approved I was making about 2,000 and
who is the lender
all right BMW Financial okay well we've
established that their financial people
are not as smart as the people that
build their cars it's a fine car but
these people are smoking crack to give
you this loan yep
I mean who give somebody a $600 car
payment with a $2,000 income their brain
damaged man their parents are cousins
that's ridiculous
Wow I'm scared for you man so yeah you
got to get that thing sold don't you yes
and I'm negative 15,000 I'm upside down
15,000 because I've rolled a negative
equity from my last BMW before that what
do you do for a new hours a week are you
working just 20 I'm a full-time student
how old are you 27 oh my gosh what are
you studying uh aircraft mechanics
that's good when will you graduate Jim
oh good okay so there's a light at the
end the tunnel on your income going up
substantially right
oh right like but this time here you out
you ought to be an aircraft mechanic
making how much probably about average
out here's about twenty to an hour yeah
okay about fifty K a year yeah okay yeah
okay that'll help cuz you know but I
don't have to get out of the mess I
don't know how you're doing it I mean
how are you eating and keeping this car
payment up well I don't have any I live
at home so I don't I don't pay rent oh
look you on that but I also have ten
thousand dollars in credit card that yes
and I'm only able to barely make the
minimum payments on our first goal our
first goal is to tread water until you
graduate and get your income way up the
second goal is do anything you can in
the interim to get your income up and
still graduate in May so we're going to
pick up more hours different job
whatever and try to get more money
coming in to throw at this mess as hard
as we can
my guess is you might be able to clean
up some of the credit card debt of
course you need to get them out and have
plastic surgery right
alright and you know get rid of them
because we don't want to use them ever
again but maybe you can whittle a few of
those away between now and May and then
when May comes in June you graduate you
get out get a much much better income
then we've start beating on this car
situation maybe we can find a way to get
some of the upside down amount covered
so that you can get it sold but I don't
I don't know if anybody's gonna loan you
fifteen thousand dollars right now to
sell this car and that's really what you
need right correct I was what do you
think about making a contractual loan
with family members well I I think it
turns the borrower is slave to the
lender and I think it turns that family
member into your master who are you
talking about either one of my two
uncles that I think are able to do it
they're willing to do it now
if I were your uncle I would love you
enough to not do that for you
I wouldn't do that
for you I would make you fight through
this because I because I think there's a
high probability you're not going to pay
them and you're gonna damage that
relationship or pay them has agreed not
because you're not a good guy but
because the mathematics of this
situation suck beyond belief does that
make sense
and so I don't I don't want if I'm your
uncle I might give you some money but
I'm not gonna loan you any money because
you are in a mess dude and you're not
gonna be able to pay it anytime soon
easily you know it's just a problem so
yeah I'm gonna just you know do
everything you can to increase your
income between now and June and then of
course in June when it goes way up and
let's get rid of that car as soon as we
possibly can and you know the good news
is you're only 27 and you got the rest
of your life to never do something this
stupid again I've done stupid stuff at
the time I was 28 I was broke man I was
bankrupt and I had zeros on the end of
the muster but you just did one car and
but dude you did it big
I mean you killed picker go home you did
it and so you got a mess on your hands
but you'll get out of this and you will
never ever look at a car payment the
same way again I hope I hope you've
learned your lesson and I hope this is
you know that's the problem with pain
you know it's it's a great teacher it's
a thorough teacher but it's pain and I
don't like to learn that way and I'm
sorry you're learning that way but dude
you're getting hammered and it's all
because you set yourself up to be the
nail and it's just wow ouch
I'll tell you what dude let me do this
hold on I'm gonna have Kelly pick up I
want you to go through Financial Peace
University our class as my guest I wish
somebody had given me that when I was
your age and shown me how to not ever do
this again and so I'll walk with you and
get you out help you get out of this cuz
you got a mess
hold on Kelly I'll pick up we'll get you
signed up for that I you know yes that
young man has made a really stupid
mistake but I got to tell you BMW
financial ought to be ashamed of
themselves I mean that's just corporate
misbehavior right there and you give a
27 year old guy a car loan
of $600 and his income is $2,000
you're freaking con-artist I mean that's
morally corrupt it's what that is so BMW
finance you ought to pick up the phone
there's not probably not a lot of guys
in Los Angeles named Feroz it's F er a Z
I don't know his last name
but you ought to pick up the phone just
forgive this loan because you guys are
absolute crooks I mean you're absolute
crooks that's just ridiculous and you
know whatever everyone that young
finance divisions of these car companies
does this stuff and all they see is a
you know meat hanging in front of them
and they're Rocky Balboa in the meat
locker and they just punch it out man
you know it's just but it's just a
reminder that you know when you're doing
business you have to do good business
with people you and I can disagree about
whether our car payments a good idea but
no one with half a freaking brain cell
thinks that car loan was morally okay
that was not okay as far as his fault -
he sat there as a grown man and signed
up for that crap but man BMW you ought
to be ashamed of yourself this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
you
[Music]